laughing hey everybody this is gonna be
my non-spoilery black panther review
you've probably been seeing a lot of the
reactions on social there's certainly a
lot of hyperbole that's been thrown
around the movie people are calling it
the best Marvel movie ever the character
certainly isn't as important to me as it
is to some people but it is one of those
movies that makes you feel like they do
have some kind of magic in the water at
Marvel because seriously we're at like
20 plus Marvel movies in the real magic
behind Black Panther is making you feel
like you're going to see a Marvel movie
for the first time because the movie is
getting ready to drop I'm also doing a
giveaway for movie tickets all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just share this video using those tools
on the watch page like imagine they've
launched this Disney streaming service
and they put all of their Marvel movies
so that you can marathon every single
one of them it would be like a season of
TV in all the episodes would feel like
150 million dollars and I think
initially the danger and the worry of a
lot of people that were decrying comic
book films this is that hey you know
there's been so many of these people are
gonna get tired they'll be fatigued but
Black Panthers the culmination of the
right actor in the right role with the
right supporting cast with the right
director in the right studio to become
one of the crown jewels of all comic
book films to make as many puns about
being a king as possible because you
sometimes forget that Black Panther is
one of the few Avengers like Thor that
is a genuine king in his own domain so
like we just got that infinity war
trailer we have mustache Bros because
dr. strange and Tony Stark are on-screen
together now we have King Bros because
we'll have Thor and black panther
together on screen eventually there's
been a lot of talk about Black Panther
box-office it smashed all the pre-sales
orders so people were like this is gonna
make billions of dollars now I certainly
think that it's good enough to make a
lot of money but I still think that
infinity war will probably be the
biggest comic book earner of the year
just because it's the 10th anniversary
of Marvel Studios but what a coincidence
that a movie like this this is good as
Black Panther also drops during Marvel's
10th anniversary I think most of the
credit has to go to Ryan Coogler in
Chadwick Boseman
because if you don't believe in your
king then it's really like a house of
cards or a house of glass
that you build your kingdom on it was
just crumble at the sign of any cracks
you may have heard the story about how
Marvel cast him as Black Panther during
Civil War like they were literally
sitting the powers-that-be around this
big table Kevin Feige with the Russo
brothers although other bigger producers
and all at the same time they said
chadwick boseman he was their topic
every single one they called him up boom
he became the Black Panther no auditions
necessary
they made Robert Downey jr. audition for
Iron Man I should you not please call me
Tony
I mean seriously Harry are you sweating
balls in the desert you're fighting for
our freedom back home and it's it's
ghastly the conditions there's not a
woman in sight yes clearly although I
retract that statement I'd like to admit
that but again I think a lot of that
just in the idea that they're so good at
spotting talent so you have to also give
a lot of credit to Kevin Feige and the
other producers for creating the
environment where things like this can
happen like laying the groundwork so
that you can build movies like this so
obviously all these movies are really
popular even if it was just okay it
would still make a crap ton of money
there are tons of comic book films that
are just okay but at this point people
just expect so much of Marvel because
they've had so many hits that everything
will be a hit so Black Panther had to
clear that hurdle like you have to be
great otherwise people will think you're
terrible like there is no middle ground
for a character like this somebody who's
set up to be one of the biggest badasses
of the Avengers somebody who's written
so that he could become the eventual
next leader of The Avengers should
things change in Marvel phase four now
don't get me wrong the movie is by no
means perfect
every good Marvel movie has its weak
points so like you saw those fight
scenes during Civil War
Black Panther moves like none of the
other vendors have moved before and it
can look kind of weird on screen now
that you have like two kind of versions
of that during the film because of the
kill monger character it can get a
little weird during their big fight
scenes so some of that can take you out
of the movie if you're just not
expecting it like wow this is getting a
little cartoonish but I think at this
point you're sort of tuned for comic
book films so you know kind of what to
expect when they get to those big
airport battle types
and they do certainly have their version
of an airport battle like we're just a
bunch of stuff is happening on screen at
once so even though I thought they did
nail a lot of the big fight scenes like
they have great action I don't think
that it will change the way you feel
about that in comic book movies so if
you're totally down for that kind of
stuff then the movie just is more of
that but if you're someone who really
just likes it when they're talking
together on screen like the really
dramatic moments it also delivers on
that too like I said because the cast is
so good those do wind up being some of
the best moments of the film the non
action scenes when a lot of stuff is
happening even though they're not
clawing each other's eyes out but one of
the other best things about the film is
the music so like when we got to Luke
Cage they hyped up the soundtrack this
is that on steroids like seriously they
got Kendrick Lamar to write original
music you've probably seen some of the
tracks on the trailers that they've been
playing there are that many times when
you get as hyped up for the music for a
big comic book film as you are for the
movie itself it's sort of like a Star
Wars movie where the music is such an
important part of the story as well just
being really awesome but part of the fun
of the Black Panther movie is is that
obviously this is all happening in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe this is all
shared events so you have all this stuff
that happened in all the movies before
and the other parts of the world somehow
Black Panther finds a way to integrate
all that yet feel like it's completely
self-contained and the funny thing is is
that sort of written into the DNA of the
movie itself in the story what Conda is
the eldorado of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like you've heard that dialogue
and all the trailers so there's this
certain mystery to it like you're
discovering this hidden gem that you've
never seen before so it looks and feels
very different from other Marvel movies
but I gotta say Ryan Coogler just gets
that character the same way that the
Russos got the characters during Captain
America Winter Soldier so like they
understood Captain America they
understood Black Widow which is why
everybody's trying to get the Russos to
come back to do the Black Widow movie
but when a director really understands
what people are looking for in a movie
and understands who the character is in
the comics and finds a way to sort of
bring that all together it just becomes
something really special it's like when
the Deadpool movie happened you know you
have an actor like Ryan Reynolds
who just fully embodies a character and
something that just surprises people
it's just so different from comic book
movies that you've seen before it just
winds up being the best thing ever so
Black Panther is another one of those
types of movies you have an actor that
sort of made the character his own so
that when people think about Black
Panther they'll think about Chadwick
Boseman
like when you walk down the street and
you ask somebody who Iron Man is they
say Oh Robert Downey jr. is Iron Man
they don't say Tony Stark so obviously
he was fantastic as the character during
the movie but Michael B Jordan like I've
said before probably one of the best
Marvel villains since Loki even K
planchette Stella
fantastic actress but whereas the Thor
Ragnarok script didn't quite pay enough
service to her I think I think she was
capable of so much more Black Panther
finds a way to be this crazy big Marvel
movie yet somehow give the villain a
genuine arc so like you really
understand where he's coming from and
you sympathize with his story you know
there's certainly a meta thing going on
because we all saw that Fantastic Four
movie so this is the role that Michael B
Jordan was born for in the Marvel movies
even though hopefully Marvel does get
those x-men based characters the
Fantastic Four so we can make all kinds
of jokes when they come in because don't
forget now we have two versions of the
Human Torch
so if you're someone who has seen pretty
much every comic book film there's
certainly like a meta aspect to it that
just makes it that much more fun
the movies much more of a political
thriller than Winter Soldier was and
much more a movie about family I'll be
interested to see if they can top that
when we get to infinity war because the
Avengers is kind of like a family that's
broken up because of the events of Civil
War you look at some of the supporting
cast like Sheree for instance probably
one of the most interesting new
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe she's written to be somebody
who can do great things in the way that
Peter Parker is written to be someone
like that no people have been living
with spider-man for so many years that
you do any version of Peter Parker and
people just automatically know a lot of
where the characters headed like oh well
he's a young kid so very clearly he's
gonna grow up he'll become part of the
Avengers and you kind of know where he's
going but with a character like Sheree
they sort of lay the groundwork for her
to have this infinite potential they
could take the character in any
direction that they want part of the fun
of her in some of these other Newark
characters that you're meeting for the
first time is is seeing how they
integrate with the rest of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because I have a
feeling that they want people to walk
out of these movies saying what would it
be like if these characters crossed over
with these other characters so I walked
out of the movie thinking well if Cherie
is about sixteen years old and Peter
Parker's about 16 years old wouldn't it
make sense for them to cross over like
if you're gonna do a movie with younger
characters they would be the ones two of
the smartest people in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe sort of like the next
generation of Avengers like you have
these older phase one phase two Avengers
that are sort of riding off into the
sunset now you have these younger people
coming up wouldn't it be crazy if you
cross them over in the next spider-man
movie or the next Black Panther movie so
you walk out of this movie with a sense
of optimism about where they can take
all these characters now obviously they
probably already know what the sequel is
going to be and I'm betting there's
gonna be at least two sequels to this
but just in general Black Panther is one
of those movies that changes the way you
think what Marvel is capable of in the
way that the first guardians of the
galaxy movie did something that's really
different from what you've seen before
in a really good way like oh wow I never
thought that they would be able to do
something like this so they're like
that's probably the highest praise that
I can give so really the biggest problem
that they have now is is what is that
sequel going to be so I don't want to
get into really big spoilers but just in
general like the door Milosh a Sheree
Lupita Danai gurira Michael B Jordan
Andy Serkis Martin Freeman all fantastic
performances like we're getting to the
point now like I said where they could
just get any actor they want like you
want an Oscar winner they would never do
comic book movies boom they're doing
comic book movies now but if you're big
longtime comic book fan I know you're
all asking about Easter eggs post-credit
scenes I can say without spoilers there
are two post-credits scenes so make sure
you stay through the entire end credits
so I know there's a lot of questions
about how this ties in with infinity war
again those are kind of spoilery things
that we can't really talk about right
now but leave all your questions in the
comments below and once you do have a
chance to see it please let me know what
you think but please do not post
spoilers on this video there will be
more spoilery videos next week after
everyone has a chance to see the movie
so don't worry we will talk about
everything because there is a lot of
to talk about after this movie
especially considering that infinity war
is just a couple months down the road
and then within a year of that we get
Avengers four so do not forget two
back-to-back Avengers films happening
they're gonna change the face of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but black
panther is like the first big step in
that so do whatever you have to do to go
see that movie it all announced the
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
which should be tomorrow they've been a
lot of questions about that infinity war
trailer so no worries lots of infinity
war coming click here to rewatch that
Super Bowl trailer and click here to
rewatch those other Super Bowl trailers
thank you so much for watching everybody
it's that awesome I'll see you guys
tonight